so this is another one of these Laten
consistency models real time it just
takes your video webcam and then you put
the prompt down below and in this case
it was just like turning me into like a
version of Arnold uh from the
Terminators okay so there you
go wow pretty convincing it makes you
look like a badass that's first and
foremost well you're pretty badass
already but it lets you in real time
kind of play with it so again if you
were to put and wearing you know bands
would it do that wearing
sunglasses let's see what it does yeah
so edit the sunglasses yeah you can see
where this is going so I think it's a c
C+ oh that's a that's a harsh grade I'm
going to tell you no cuz it's not usable
I'm bringing usability into here you're
like the product manager and I'm the
engineer like I'm like wow that's really
hard to do no no credit for technical
achievement here talking about hey in
the real world does this
apply